québec resserre la location de type
airbnb dès le 1er mai 2020 un
propriétaire pourra louer sa résidence
principale à court terme mais devra
auparavant obtenir un numéro un numéro
d'enregistrement tous les autres
hébergements offerts en location devront
se conformer aux mêmes règles que les
hôtels les résidences secondaires mise
en location devront même payer une taxe
sur l'hébergement cloud et fauchon est
avocat chez lavery à québec madame
fauchon bonsoir quels sont les
changements majeurs dans ce projet de
loi qui a été présenté par le
gouvernement ce nouveau règlement
effectivement c'est un nouveau règlement
c'est un règlement qui a été modifiée
par dont le règlement sur les
établissements d'hébergement touristique
et le changement qui m'apparaît le plus
majeur de mon point de vue c'est
l'élargissement delà du champ
d'application en fait de ce règlement
maintenant seront visés par ce règlement
les gens qui offriront en location une
chambre une résidence chalet une maison
pour une durée d'une période pardon de
31 jours ou moins dans la mesure où
cette offre de location là et publié par
média quelconque et donc le changement
qui est majeur ici c'est qu'avant une
exigence qu'on retrouvait dans le
règlement était que l'offre devait être
faite sur une base régulière
or on ne retrouve plus cette exigence là
présentement de sorte que à compter du
1er mai 2020 soit la date d'entrée en
vigueur du règlement si par exemple je
veux offrir ma résidence en location ne
serait ce qu'une fois dans l'année
je serait assujetti au règlement pour
moins de 31 jours exactement toujours au
moins des 31 jours et donc ça va prendre
quoi une attestation de la corporation
de l'industrie touristique du québec un
numéro qui dit assujettissement aux
règlements dit obligation d'obtenir une
attestation de classification du
ministre de la ministre pardon du
tourisme donc c'est cette attestation là
qui devra être obtenu par contre on peut
souligner également qu'une nouvelle
catégorie d'établissements d'hébergement
touristique a été créé
dans le règlement justement parce que la
majorité des gens qui maintenant tu
deviennes assujettis à ce règlement sont
des personnes qui comme vous et moi
pourrait décider d'offrir en location
leur résidence
une fois dans une année donc on constate
que beaucoup plus de gens seront visés
et un allégement dans la procédure
d'obtention de cette attestation de
classification a été mis en place en vue
de sorte qu une personne qui se qualifie
comme vous et moi de l'exploitant
d'établissements d'une résidence
principale n'aura pas à faire évaluer la
qualité de son de son unité
d'hébergement n'aura pas se voir
attribuer une cote d'évaluation de 0
étoile à 5 étoiles par exemple comme
lisez comme le com dans le commercial
exactement et donc on reçoit ce numéro
on loue une fois de temps en temps moins
de 31 jours on doit afficher l'annonçons
d'affiché numéro sur le site web qu'on a
choisi pour annoncer la location de sa
résidence principale
c'est effectivement une nouvelle
obligation qui ceux qui se présentent
aux gens qui vont offrir en location
leur leur unité d'hébergement
on doit indiquer maintenant le numéro de
l'établissement d'hébergement
touristique dans son offre de location
qu on peut donc dès lors présumer que ce
sera un outil de plus pour le
gouvernement pour m'habituer
l'application de sa loi et de son
règlement évidemment bien les cons les
copropriétaires doivent avoir
l'autorisation de leur syndicat de
copropriété n'est ce pas à aller de
l'avant et c'est la même chose pour les
locataires avec les propriétaires c'est
quoi exactement en fait cette obligation
la existait déjà à la base par le biais
du code civil dont ce sont des règles du
code civil
par contre il on pouvait se retrouver
dans des situations où propriétaire
n'avait pas l'autorisation de son
syndicat de copropriété pour exploiter
un établissement d'hébergement
touristique dans le
le l'immeuble à condominiums et le
faisait quand même parce qu'il se
jugeait en droit de le faire puisqu'il
avait par ailleurs obtenu une
attestation de classification de la
ministre du tourisme cette situation là
ne devrait plus se présenter
espérons le à compter du 1er mai 2020
puisque pour obtenir une telle
attestation de classification de la
ministre du tourisme
le propriétaire qui fait partie d'un
immeuble à condominiums devra obtenir au
préalable une autorisation aux syndicats
de propriété pour pouvoir obtenir
l'attestation du minutes de la ministre
est ce que les amendes sont assez élevés
si on ne respecte pas le nouveau
règlement ah mais c'est pour répondre à
cette question là je ne peux que dire
que tout est relatif parce que par
exemple je constate que dans certaines
régions du québec est très touristique
en période hivernale la location de
chalets peut grimper le prix peut
grimper à ca de façon assez importante
et une amende pour le
ne pas avoir obtenu l'attestation
requise
lorsqu'on est une personne physique nous
rend passible d'une amende de 2500 $ et
de cet amant lui peut évidemment être
plus élevé en cas de récidive
mais 2500 $ comparativement à un chalet
qui peut être louée pour plusieurs
milliers de dollars
ce pourrait être insuffisant dans ce col
apprécié vous qu'il compte dans une
situation comme vous et moi on loue
notre modeste résidence pour quelques
jours et bien ce devrait être
suffisamment dissuasives absolument un
mot rapide en terminant la résidence
secondaire le règlement s'applique pas
sur ça la résidence secondaire ça reste
beaucoup plus exigeants faut faire
évaluer il faut avoir une attestation de
qualification exacte
donc c'est ces règles la demeure comme
elle était avant et elle implique
effectivement ses obligations la très
bien m faut chaud merci beaucoup pour
ses explications ce soir merci à vous
merci